hallo liebe zuschauer und willkommen
zurück bei sie kamen bei uns ist heute
giovanni hey hallo giovanni wo kommst du
her
ich komme aus ergibt denn
überraschenderweise denn wir dachten
giovanni wer ein italiener
ja also mein vater hat im tourismus
gearbeitet
deswegen hat er viele namen aus dem fell
hat er sich den schönsten rausgenommen
giovannis hatte bei uns und wir machen
heute eine neue episode heute mal zum
thema deutsche grammatik und giovanni
wird heute mal die menschen fragen in
deutschland wie das mit den fällen ist
nur selbst seit wann lernst du deutsch
ich schnell bedeutet seit zehn monaten
ziemlich krass nach zehn monaten spricht
ja schon fließend deutsch ein sehr gutes
vorbild
und natürlich fragt jetzt mal die leute
nach den deutschen fällen speziell
nachdem akkusativ wir sind gespannt was
die leute straße antworten ob sie
überhaupt antworten können verstehen die
deutschen können die deutschen überhaupt
ihre eigene grammatik erklären
wir sind gespannt hier ist ein mikrofon
welche fälle gibt es im deutschen online
archiv genitiv akkusativ auch nicht
lange in der schule keine ahnung genitiv
dativ akkusativ motiv aber nicht in der
reihenfolge glaubt noch relativ ist der
erste nomination eadv dort die partie
und konnten sie uns beispiele beispiele
der mann des mannes dem man den mann gut
okay danke schön
welche filme gibt es im deutschen welche
fälle ich glaube da bin ich die ganz
falsche person genitiv dativ damit hört
schon auch ich bin sehr gut im deutschen
aber alles ganz intuitiv
da bin ich überfragt welche wünsche
domina tief genitiv dativ und akkusativ
herzlich willkommen in der das akademie
in berlin
die deutsche akademie für sprache wir
sind hier am rosenthaler platz und ich
möchte euch ein paar tipps geben zum
deutsch lernen also die das akademie ist
schon das stichwort der die dass die
artikel ist das wichtigste der die oder
das ist halt ich sage das ist das buch
das ist der tisch das ist die lampe okay
das sehr wichtig und intuition hilft da
nicht habe zb ich habe der junge das ist
maskulin gebäude
der junge das ist klar okay aber die
mädchen der die oder das mädchen das
mädchen erneut rom
das mädchen ist ein bisschen komisch
aber es stimmt das mädchen das heißt
keine intuition lernen lernen lernen
leider wie viele fälle gibt es im
deutschen viele viele fälle ja vier oder
angesetzt deutlich negativ genitiv
fünften der die dass dieser artikel
brauchen dennoch für die fälle mit den
vier fälle
es gibt vier fälle also fall meisten
domina tief was gibt's noch negativ
akkusativ genitiv und das ok auf welche
fragen beantworten
ja diese fälle
wer oder was nomi nativ wen oder was
akkusativ wem oder was dativ und west
den akkusativ erkläre ich immer mit
werben also die meisten werben brauchen
den akkusativ zum beispiel zum beispiel
haben
kennen
mögen
essen trinken das sind so die ersten
werben die man lernt mit dem akkusativ
ich sehe dass das ist ein typischer satz
mit akkusativ also ich zu sehr ein
objekt aus dem bach ich sehe das buch
das sind noch werben mit adretten ich
sehe ich finde zum beispiel ich finde
das buch was noch ich habe okay was noch
ich kaufe das buch sehr gut
ich kaufe das
oder ich suche das buch ok sehr gut
auch hier wieder ich subjekt kaufe was
ein objekt das buch ok mit das buch ist
es sehr relativ simpel ich kaufe das
buch ich sehe das buch jetzt machen wir
das mit till lampe ich kaufe die lange
auch simpel mit femininen ich kaufe die
lampard aber der tisch machen
88 ich kaufe den tisch alles klar
ok du kannst du eigentlich selber den
akkusativ ja wir machen ein test okay
okay ich sag dir was das ist und du
musst das mit akkusativ verantworten
das ist der lkw was siehst du ja ich
sehe den lkw
okay das ist das haus was siehst du ich
sehe das haus richtig dass bleibt das
auch im akkusativ da kommt die tram
was siehst du ich sehe einen traum die
tramway prammer den tisch okay ihr wisst
schon
maskulin akkusativ aus der wirt den ok
und dass deswegen ist es sehr wichtig zu
wissen ist es der die oder das okay wenn
ich weiß es ist der das ist der tisch
dann ist es auch den tisch ich lehne den
tisch und ich kaufe den tisch also auch
hier akkusativ ist sehr wichtig zu
wissen ist es maskuline feminin oder es
neutral
also ich sag immer immer mit in die
unbestimmte blicken
ja das geht eigentlich auch ich sehe
eine straßenbahn ich sehe ein haus ich
sehe einen lkw film mal da machen wir
schnell da kommt gerade einen
einkaufswagen aus dem elternhaus oder
kommt die tram der tram dieser sehe eine
tram oder ich sehe die tram the drum
denn auch die weil dem femininen bleibt
es auch gleich richtig domina tief ist
es die und im akkusativ auch also bei
chemie bleibt die und
bei nominal also mein traum bleibt so
und nur im maskulinum ändert es von der
auf dem genau ich sehe den lkw das ist
das auto was siehst du ich sehe ein
alter das ist eine jacke was siehst du
diese ein recke das ist das haus was
siehst du ein aus das ist ein poller was
ich so sehr einen poller die vielen
fehler im deutschen gibt
das kann ich gar nicht so genau sagen
ich glaube das wissen die deutschen
selbst nicht und wenn ihr mehr über die
wunderbare welt wissen wollt von der das
kommt doch einfach in die das akademie
in berlin
wir danken besteht du bist zurück was
mich mal interessieren würde konnten die
deutschen die überhaupt erklären was der
akkusativ ist naja die meisten von ihnen
haben gut elf klärung gemacht aber die
meisten auch die also einen darf
manninen sie wissen überhaupt nicht aber
die akkusativ und sie können nicht das
erklären also sie haben sie benutzen das
deutlich im alltag und sie wissen das
wie kann man das wilden so ist das wenn
man die sprache kann kann man sie ja
nicht unbedingt erklären und ich glaube
viele deutsche kennen die fälle oder
können die fälle zumindest auch nicht
erklären
ich hoffe die hat es trotzdem geholfen
diese episode ja so und ich habe mich
sehr gefreut darüber ja wir haben uns
sehr gefreut dass da was wir hoffen es
hat euch auch gefreut und das war's
schon mit dieser woche mit der episode
diese woche wir hoffen es hat euch
gefallen
ihr habt ein bisschen was gelernt über
den akkusativ wenn ihr mehr easy german
sehen wollt dann guckt unbedingt hier
klickt ihr auf den bakken subscribe und
wenn ihr uns unterstützen wollt damit
wir mehr videos noch drehen können
dann könnt ihr mal zum training kommen
da haben wir auch viele extras und
outtakes
wir freuen uns danke dass du dabei weißt
du über linke und bis bald